[Musique]
de la musique et des cadeaux et des
traditions forcément pour noël
aujourd'hui nous allons un peu voyagé
tout d'abord avec vous grégory direction
l italie et la bad huîtres nous voilà
pendant pas du tout mes joueurs assure
ses produits tout aussi gourmands ils
sont un peu différents l'heure devant
moi vous connaissez forcément le
panettone je vois la preuve prononcer
avec l'accent italien le comment vous
dites le panettone nicolas alexandre est
pas mal à vous connaissez c'est une
brioche qui vient donc d'italie une
brioche sucré et garni de raisin et
fruits secs ça c'est pour la version
classique
car depuis son invention au xvème siècle
a milan il s'est exportée dans toutes
les régions d'italie et s'est déclinée
en plusieurs recettes un restaurant
situé avenue du centre à montigny le
bretonneux qui fait également traiteur
et épicerie fine propose toute une gamme
de panettone venus d'italie leçon aux
fruits rouges annabis rien ou encore
sans gluten alors si vous voulez ici à
la maison oscar pato on est sur un
panier classique uniquement aux raisins
pas qu'on peut avoir d'autres méthodes
comme la marraine lafabrie que petites
cerises amarena fabrice et ligne des
plus grandes maisons
la marée la coop en excellence rien à
dire
après on peut avoir d'autres personnes
également je prends par an pour les gens
qui mangent sans gluten un petit goûter
au multi
et encore une autre maison et oui nos
maisons un peu différent qui est très
bien aussi
après la douche bail d'un an je vais
dire ma remplacer projet de quotas on
fait un peu toutes sortes de palets toi
maintenant de longs jours
bon il a emballé on le déguste ras tout
à l'heure en plateau en italie à noël
aussi on apprécier le chocolat pas
n'importe lequel on dit là john douilles
nicolas la douille gianduja on peut dire
jean audouze a en france et voilà on
reconnaît l'agent double j'ai asseyé
c'est un peu moins exotique au chocolat
très crémeux aux noisettes qui nous
vient du piémont c'est la base de la
recette d'une célèbre pâte à tartiner
que vous appréciez sans doute autour de
la table et accusé nicolas non je me
permettrai pas nicolas côtés de ses
marques de grande distribution il ya
aussi des marques reconnues pour leur
qualité comme cette maison turinoise une
maison qui s'appelle vincit récoltant
guillemant ou là on fait le terrain
voisin du monde la maisonnée tripoli
pour leur petit chocolat mais cuba aura
voilà c'est l'une des principes tant
qu'ils sont connus comme savoir les
petits cappuccino jeu colloque la
puccino au tiramisu également est à
présent également un peu sympa aussi ont
ajouté les chocolats on va dire un peu
différente des gens mais désuet la saic
motor
ve
différents goûts à orange c'est pas mal
j'apprécie le panettone si je prononce
bien est emballé juste devant vous est
donné à nicolas par exemple par hasard
pour l'ouvrir on va lui demander aussi
de couper peut-être ça commence bien les
deux tranches par contre nicolas
attention à pas vous couper alors pas
que des choses à manger il ya aussi des
des choses à boire sur les tables
italiennes d alcool à consommer bien sûr
avec modération le vin bien sûr dans les
italiens à dire ont forcément que c'est
le meilleur du monde notamment des vin
blanc pétillant que l'on peut consommer
à la place de champagne
comme vous devez le savoir en italie a
pas de champagne mais un concurrent le
splm hanter le secouement tc comme le
champagne
sauf que la paroisse l'appellation
champagne la saison qui s'appelle mal
copa do so très connu pour les barreaux
lobo cia qui est pour moi l'un des
meilleurs vins au monde sans portion
nebiolo comme le post comme le commenter
c'est également dîné viol au jeu cépages
du barolo ça va être un petit peu rosé
doré moi j'apprécie beaucoup comparé à
un champagne va payer ça beaucoup moins
cher et je trouve que c'est meilleur et
on va terminer avec le meilleur moment
de cette chronique la dégustation alors
que nicolas est en train de déballer de
manière tout à fait discret tout à fait
discret qui le caractérise nouvelles en
italie natale
ça se dit natale et natal et ça s'écrit
voilà alors le panettone que vous êtes
en train de déballer sympa la tour de 10
dans l'oreiller puisque l'ingénieur du
son est décédé
en train de frotter sa c'est un
panettone aux fruits rouges que pour
vous pouvez retrouver bien sûr dans
l'enseignement je parlais tout à l'heure
à montigny le bretonneux avec d'autres
produits d'ailleurs toutes les
informations sont à retrouver sur le
lien qui s'affiche en bas d'écran
effectivement vous pouvez saupoudrer le
panettone avec se doute qu'elle est le
sucre voilà qui a fourni à 0 bref comme
vous qui re comme le chantait en tout à
fait voilà moi j'ai une question
solution italienne c'est pas le père
noël fit amman et cadeaux alors aux fans
c'est bien alors en fait à noël si c'est
le père noël donc on dit babeau natal
est effectivement au moment de
l'épiphanie donc c'est à dire sous début
janvier la befana qui est une sorcière
amène également des cadeaux donc les
italiens alors c'est pas vraiment noël
mais ils ont deux fois des cadeaux alors
on saupoudre et colas cela si on peut
voir effectivement en italien on a une
semaine de congé supplémentaire pour
pour fêter la betterave garantie c'est
que c'est bien du sucre dans le sachet
oui c'est l'iran qui coûtait nicolas
nicolas
il veille à la présentation du colloque
non non vous ne trouvez pas oui c'était
plus mal gaulle à sable à quoi peut-être
continuer pendant au moins on ne lui
donne un petit coup de main ou on va
déguster pendant votre juste après c'est
quoi le goût particulier il ya un bassin
aux fruits rouges
voilà alors le panettones classics et
des fruits des raisins secs et s'est
déclinée à maintenant depuis sa création
s'est déclinée en plusieurs goût des
fruits rouges on en trouve aussi aux
marrons glacés
ben voilà il vraiment en plein au
chocolat tout à fait il ya vraiment
plein de vous les uns les autres vous
avez des traditions dans vos familles
respectives
mais l'animal de pense mal de progrès se
nourrissent de dessert les treize
desserts de noël par un 13e bol d'or
c'est les calissons
aix en provence parce que j'aime cette
ville là avec les mandarines les c'est
pas une petite chose qu'en général je
ramène d'ailleurs après le 1er janvier
ouellette géant barre-de-monts
combattent un bon et on mange bien on a
les huîtres à côté ouais sur des
traditions
j'ai la chance d'avoir un papa cuisine
et donc je me jetterai pas forcément
nicolas dans le sud-ouest le fameux foie
gras et puis tous les produits dérivés
du canard donc que ce sens malgré ou en
et canards vivants les canards morts
tous qui canard fumé très bon nous on
voit du prosecco le prosecco assez bien
lobby italien dans sa carrière prégnance
de la pression je vais bien que le nom à
consonance italienne oui c'est vrai tout
à fait bon personne de la coupe et on
goûtera paris
[Musique]